rossi are you chompity chomping at that
bridgerton bit oh i'm chomping to chomp
chomp chomping
[Music]
first up we have got some fresh kim
kanye
pete davidson news okay
they love this 2022 thing you didn't
know you needed the blog she knows
reports that kanye's got a song out it's
brand new with some fighting words for
pete davidson but allegedly pete finds
it hilarious
the lyrics are god saved me from that
crash so i can beat pete davidson's
you-know-what
what pops will crash you didn't say you
know what
exactly finesse allegedly pete never
wants to feud with kanye because that's
the dad of kim's kids plus he expected
to be referenced in one of his songs
sooner or later discuss oh god
right are you into this
i absolutely love it we knew kanye was
going to do this yeah i mean did we
expect less no no and i think pete
absolutely loves it he's happy about it
the thing is i think he's a little
afraid
just a little bit pete yes pete's a
little afraid really yes it's but he's
not afraid of kanye
he's afraid of kanye's fan
well first up our story today it's gonna
be wedding bells for machine gun kelly
and megan fox yes but we got details on
that ring
and i liked finding out what they were
people reports that machine gun kelly
designed it himself he also designed it
with thorn tips so that if megan tries
to take it off it hurts a little bit
okay well that feels very in keeping
with them a little torture a little um
the ring is actually two rings one
emerald for her birthstone
one diamond for his another detail i
liked knowing and then the two are
attracted to each other by a magnet that
snaps them together what's this couple
gonna do next rossi i'm here for this uh
you know i'm here for it too i'm glad
they found each other because
they said after they got engaged they
drank each other's blood yeah i'm cute
okay and then
um which again i couldn't tell if they
were being jokey or serious i never know
but i'm here for all of it
great news bridgeton fans any bridgerton
fans oh hello
and i are big bridgeton fans in season
two it's on its way back thank you march
25th and i can't speak english but i can
do an english accent we've got some
sneak peeks polygon reports that this
season will focus on anthony
bridgerton's love life and a fiery
connection that he develops with a real
spark plug
named kate played by simone ashley rossi
are you chompity chomping at that
bridgerton bit oh i'm chomping to trump
trump chomping yes i cannot wait i mean
i'm i almost put a corset on today just
to get ready for it
i am so excited i the show is full of
passion it's beautiful the sex scenes i
don't know if you've seen it
but they're intense and i miss them
all right next we've seen all those
decorative wooden plaques with the words
live laugh love on them well this one is
so awesome this story because apparently
the phrase has become a huge
joke for gen c okay yahoo life reports
that live laugh love is being now mocked
by millions of people especially the
younger ones on tick tock every day some
in sort of this tone like this video do
you see this kelly look it says
live
laugh
love
isn't that precious you know we don't
have anything over the couch in the den
i guess i'm gonna have to get it it's
just too
it's just too perfect for a family live
laugh love so simple
okay so that's one approach but they're
also using it like i just got ghosted
again live laugh love i just filed for
bankruptcy live laugh love jay what's
your take on live laugh love well you
know i'm going to play a bit of devil's
advocate here right i think we need a
little more live laugh love in our life
but not not on a plaque not not in your
home
[Music]